gracias por esta comunicación doctor
gonzález rusia invitó a las partes a
negociar en moscú el consejo de
seguridad de naciones unidas pide un
cese el fuego inmediato y gran parte de
la comunidad internacional llama al
diálogo cómo podemos dimensionar la
importancia mundial de estas tensiones
sin resolver desde hace más de tres
décadas
bueno creo que es claro que estamos en
los últimos días de esta crisis
militarizada entre armenia y azerbaiyán
por la zona de la cara baja
y seguramente hacia el fin de semana
el día viernes comenzamos al poder las
primeras
expresiones de mayor cercanía para
encarar un diálogo que seguramente como
sucedió en anteriores crisis va a estar
apadrinado por moscú moscú tiene usted
en un rol muy importante porque hemos no
es afín a sus intereses que haya tanta
inestabilidad en el cáucaso ambos países
forman parte del lo que fue la unión
soviética y tienen una relación muy
cercana a moscú por eso creo que aquí el
factor y hoy vimos la invitación que ha
hecho lávrov el ministro de exteriores y
algunas expresiones rusas las cuales
invitaban a evitar
el despliegue de milicianos provenientes
de siria para ambos lados es que era un
primer paso que va a marcar un poco el
ritmo de esta bueno este fin que
esperemos que se dé lo más pronto
posible porque bueno como bien sabemos
hay muchas vidas que se están perdiendo
seguimos hablando de los actores
internacionales doctor y es que el
ministro de defensa de azerbaiyán dijo
que con la ayuda del ejército turco
azerbaiyán cumpliría su sagrado deber de
recuperar los territorios perdidos es
que el apoyo de turquía está
envalentonando azerbaiyán
creo que el apoyo de turquía es un
factor más dentro de esta disputa
pero tenemos que tener en cuenta que el
conflicto por un adorno karabaj tiene su
propia dinámica tanto debemos armenia
que conquistó los territorios por vía
militar en la guerra de los 80 el
principio de 90 y además anexo una serie
de territorios que ya no son parte de
esta región original y por el contrario
observación que vemos con el aval de
turquía
y en general la comunidad internacional
que no reconoce digamos esta república
auto digamos
autor expresada que está bajo control de
los armenios y que se ubica era lo que
observaciones hablan del alto karabaj
entonces turquía es un actor más importa
es uno de los actores importantes en
este conflicto pero la línea de la
dinámica es básicamente entre armenia
que por ejemplo modificó su estrategia
de seguridad nacional con una posición
más ofensiva que se vayan y no tiene
digamos quiere cambiar el status quo
porque se ve dificultado ya no se ve
vemos qué parte de su territorio luego
de su independencia fue estimado por
reportar mente